bienvenidos a la complejidad de las
restas con dos y tres números vamos a
hacer un ejercicio para recordar lo que
hemos hecho en los vídeos anteriores
empecemos con cuánto es 16 menos 4 la
manera en que hemos visto esto
normalmente es a través de aprendernos
los de memoria poco a poco se lo sabrán
y eso es parte de esos ejercicios que
les comentaba que es interesante hagan
restas entre números del 10 al 20 y
restando números de un solo dígito si
hacemos esto en la línea de los números
tendremos una línea así en la que
pondremos 17 16 15 14 13 12 11 10 9 8
creo que hice demasiado grande esta
línea no importa de todos modos la
tendremos aquí y empezaremos en 5 vamos
a hacer una vez más el recorrido hacia
la izquierda en esta línea porque
estamos restando empezamos en el 16 y
nos colocamos aquí para restar 4
espacios
16 1 es 15 menos 214 menos 3 13 menos
412 podemos decir que 16
4 son 12 y también pudiéramos hacer los
16 dibujos ya saben limones pelotas y
quitar 4 sin embargo vamos a empezar a
tener nuevos mecanismos para hacer estas
y estás restas e incluso otras más
complicadas un poco más sencillas veamos
otra manera de ver este 16 menos 4 va a
ser igual
recuerdan que en las sumas hemos
dividido nuestros espacios de acuerdo a
columnas haremos lo mismo en las restas
16 es igual a decir que tenemos una
moneda de 10 + 6 moneditas de un peso
o de la misma manera este 4 realmente
son 4 unidades 4 moneditas de peso
lo que haremos es hacer lo siguiente
dividimos nuestra columna en unidades
y decenas
que si lo vemos aquí estas son las
escenas y estas son las unidades
de tal manera que si dividimos en
columnas tendremos 64 es igual a 2
cambiamos el color para hacerlo más
visible es igual a 2
y diez menos cero es igual a 10 en este
caso este 10 realmente lo que está
haciendo es representado por este uno
tenemos una decena más seis unidades por
lo tanto este bajará directo
y llegamos exactamente el mismo número
64 es igual a 2 y aquí como hemos puesto
10 es igual a 1 está sencillo ahora
vamos a empezar a ver números un poco
más complejos
hagamos espacio aquí
vamos a hacer una nueva resta que será
un tanto más complicada cuánto será 78
menos 37
aquí podemos analizar de distintas
maneras de entrada podemos ver que 78 si
es un número más grande que 37 por lo
que el resultado que tendremos aquí va a
ser un número positivo es decir que a 78
efectivamente le podemos quitar 37
podemos hacer tal vez 78 estrellas si
apagamos 37 o
o hacerlo con pelotas sin embargo nos
tomaremos toda una vida para hacer eso
lo que haremos es hacer exactamente lo
mismo que hicimos hace un momento
separaremos en columnas
y haremos el análisis otra vez 8 es más
grande que el 7 por lo tanto será
sencillo y 7 es más grande que 3 por lo
tanto también será sencillo hagamos
nuestras restas directamente por cada
columna recuerden que primero tomaremos
las unidades y después las decenas
78 es igual a 70 más 8
y 37 es igual a 37 son distintas maneras
de verlo tomaremos unidades 871 que es
exactamente este 1 y nos vamos
directamente a las decenas recuerda que
aquí solo lo estoy separando para que
sea más obvio sin embargo aquí
restaremos siete decenas menos tres
decenas es igual a cuatro
así tenemos que 78 menos 37 es igual a
41 aquí haremos 70 menos 30 es igual a
40 41 es igual a 40 más uno que es
exactamente el mismo resultado vamos a
hacer
95 - 31
y volvamos a hacer el análisis que hemos
hecho hace un momento dividimos nuestra
columna y pondremos unidades y decenas
el 5 es más grande que el 1 sí entonces
estará fácil el 9 es más grande que 3 si
también será más fácil ahora vamos 5
menos uno es igual a cuatro esto se lo
van a ir aprendiendo poco a poco de
acuerdo ya la memoria ustedes van
avanzando con esto 9 menos 3 es igual a
6 95 menos 31 es igual a 64 vamos bien
vamos entonces a poner algo un poco más
complejo cuántos serán 22 menos 17
aquí empieza a ponerse más interesante
esto porque porque si dividimos nuestras
columnas como lo hemos hecho
anteriormente
tendremos que de derecha a izquierda el
2 es más pequeño que el 7 en las
unidades y tenemos que las decenas el 2
es más grande que el 1 entonces este
será más fácil y este tiene un punto que
ahorita vamos a explicar vamos a poner
una estrellita lo que haremos en este
caso es volver a separar cuál es la
composición de nuestro número 20 más 2
es igual a 22
y 17 es igual a 10 7
ok ahora de cualquier manera este 2 es
más pequeño que el 7 a 2 no le puedo
quitar 7 aún no hemos aprendido nada de
eso lo que haremos es pedirle prestado a
las decenas por lo que haremos lo
siguiente vamos a cambiar color esta
decena la cambiaremos le vamos a quitar
le vamos a pedir prestado un 1 este 2 se
convertirá en un 1 por lo que ahora será
10 más y el 10 que hemos quitado la
decena que hemos quitado la sumaremos a
este lado 22 es igual a 20 más 2 pero
también es igual a 10 más 12 ahora 12 ya
es más grande que el 7 si hacemos
nuestra nueva resta tenemos que 12
porque hemos tomado prestado de aquí 12
menos siete es igual a 5
y 1010 es igual a cero
por lo tanto 22 7 es igual a 5 estamos
claros esta explicación que hemos hecho
realmente es para que podamos entender
de donde estamos tomando prestado más
adelante lo haremos más mecánico y esto
es exactamente la misma lógica que se
utiliza para números enormes ustedes ya
han hecho sumas con números enormes
ahora las restas también son posibles
con esta cantidad de 10 15 20 dígitos
siempre y cuando llevemos la misma
secuencia y la misma lógica que hemos
manejado en este previo ok
hagamos otro cuánto será ahora 703
- 67
nuestra división ahora de columnas se
hace más grande y estamos teniendo tres
columnas
la de las unidades
la de las decenas y la de las centenas
vamos a hacer el análisis una vez más el
3 es más pequeño que el 7 entonces
haremos por aquí un préstamo el 0 es más
pequeño que el 6 eso implica que también
haremos un préstamo y el 7 es más grande
que el 0 que tenemos aquí recuerden que
si no hay nada es un cero entonces éste
estará sencillo lo queremos ahora es
dividir y agrupar de acuerdo a la
categoría centenas de sen las unidades
así es que 703 es igual a 700
los siete centenas
+ 0 decenas
tres unidades ahorita lo veremos en
cuestiones de dinero 67 será seis
decenas
767 es decir aquí tenemos siete billetes
de 100 pesos
veámoslo en cuestiones de dinero aquí
tenemos monedas de 10 pesos
y aquí tenemos moneditas de un peso lo
que ahora haremos es 37 no lo puedo
hacer lo que haremos es volver a prestar
tomar prestado pero del 0 no puedo tomar
prestado nada se dan cuenta es 0 lo que
haremos entonces es decirnos hasta las
centenas de 700 claro que puedo pedir
prestado entonces haremos lo siguiente a
700 le vamos a pedir una de sus unidades
por lo que si ahora tenemos 6 unidades
de 100 equivale a 600
ok y tachamos este 700 en la columna de
decenas ahora tendremos 10 monedas de 10
pesos por lo que serán 100 y ahora si
puedo pedirle prestado este 3 ya que
tiene de donde poder tomarlo es como si
tomáramos uno de los billetes de 100
pesos lo convirtiéramos en 10 moneditas
de 10 pesos
y haremos entonces el préstamo que
ocupamos para este 3
este 100 lo convertiremos en 90
y tendremos aquí 10 monedas de
más las tres unidades que ya teníamos
tenemos 13 esta resta si la podemos
hacer
13 - 7 es igual a 9
vamos viendo de dónde
90 que fue nuestro último préstamo 90
menos 60 es igual a 30 colocaremos 30 y
este 600 va a dejar exactamente porque
ya estamos restando les cero entonces
600 más 30 más 9 es igual a 639 donde el
9 pertenece a las unidades que es este
vamos a cambiar el color este tres de
las decenas corresponde a estas tres
decenas y este seis que tenemos aquí
corresponde a las centenas 703 menos 67
es igual a 639 una manera más en la que
podemos hacerlo de forma más mecánica
será la siguiente voy a bajar esto
volvamos a colocar nuestra operación
original 703 menos 67
ahora iremos de izquierda a derecha
hacemos nuestra división y vemos que 7
es mayor que 0
ok 0 es menor que seis aquí prestaremos
y 3 es menor que 7 aquí prestaremos lo
que podemos hacer es lo siguiente
ponemos un pequeño numerito aquí que nos
indique que estamos tomando 13 menos 7
es igual a 9
pero recuerda que nosotros tomamos 1
este número por lo tanto se convertirá
en 7
bien este uno lo tome prestado de aquí y
entonces lo llevaré
para poder hacer lo siguiente 1 6 7
ahora 7 y este es un cero tenemos la
misma situación que aquí tomaremos
prestado uno nuevo y ahora tendremos 10
este lo estamos tomando de la siguiente
columna ya verán ahora tenemos 10 menos
7 es igualdad 3
y ahora este uno que tomamos prestado de
la columna de las centenas lo
colocaremos aquí siete menos uno es
igual a seis
por lo tanto llegamos al mismo resultado
700 367 es igual a 639 recuerden que
estos números los estoy colocando en
diferentes colores para que se den
cuenta que lo tomamos prestado en uno
pero los sumamos en otro lo tomamos
prestado en uno y lo sumamos en la
siguiente columna tal vez puedan creer
que esto de la resta se está muy
complicado pero es cuestión de hacer
práctica
ahora tenemos un nuevo ejercicio vamos a
hacer espacio cuánto será
953 -754
hagamos el análisis y la separación como
lo hemos hecho previamente
3 es menor que 4 habrá un préstamo
5 al menos es igual que 5 entonces se ve
bien 9 es mayor que 7 por lo tanto
también se ve bien al 3 no le podemos
restar 4 necesitamos que este número sea
mucho mayor por lo tanto tomaremos
prestado de la columna de las decenas de
estas son las decenas unidades y
centenas
tomaremos prestado uno por lo que este
ahora se convertirá en cuatro y nosotros
tenemos un 3
nuestra columna ahora se ve bien 13 4 es
factible pero aquí nos ha quedado algo
algo distinto ahora 4 es menor que 5 por
lo que tomaremos prestado de esta
columna se convertirá en 8 y este se
convertirá en 14
vamos bien tomamos una de las centenas
para tomarla a las decenas la quitamos
de las centenas y las sumamos en las
decenas y ahora 8 menos 7 es factible
entonces veamos 13 menos 4 es igual a 9
correcto 14 menos 5 es igual a 9 y el
último número que nos quedó fue 8 menos
7 es igual a 1 953 menos 754 es igual a
199 podemos hacerlo de la manera
mecánica que les había comentado hace un
momento cambiamos el color algo más
brillante
953 -754 lo haremos mecánicamente
a 3 no le puedo quitar 4 por lo que
tomaremos prestado 1 y 13 4 es igual a 9
este uno que tome prestado ahora se lo
sumaría 5
y tenemos 6 sin embargo a 5 no le puedo
quitar 6 tomaremos prestado con otro
color 1 de aquí y este se convertirá en
quince menos seis es igual a nueve
recuerden de dónde sale este seis de
cinco más uno
este uno que tome prestado lo voy a
pagar aquí 17 es igual a 89 menos 8 es
igual a 1 de la misma manera volvimos a
quedar en 199
es importante que ustedes practiquen de
acuerdo a la que mejor están entendiendo
vamos a seguir con estos vídeos y
seguiremos practicando para que podamos
tener muchísimo mejor muchísima mayor
facilidad de hacerlos ok con calma lo
importante al igual que las sumas es que
practiquemos y practiquemos yo sé que
tal vez en unos días o meses regresen a
este primer vídeo y digan cara y estaba
muy sencillo y si la verdad es que está
sencillo es cuestión de práctica nos
estamos viendo entonces en el siguiente
vídeo